hello and welcome to this video playing
black against PR 796 PR 796 okay let's
see what we get okay well the color
system opening whatever their various
ways okay plays it in a very yeah what's
the right word down in a somewhat
conservative way is that the way to put
it you can also play it with the c4 and
more actively but maybe he wants to go
Knight e5 and build build a stone ball
I'm not sure what he's doing there a3
why would you weaken yourself on the
queenside hmm tough the same anyway I
have normal moves and he's weakening
himself that's okay I don't mind dad I
mean this is not losing or anything but
what is before doing for what I don't
see it
okay now here we are now Knight if
father comes into consideration even
more it was a good move from before and
it's it's interesting here now so Quincy
to some do I go f5 here even and then he
has a C form a C form plan now probably
I'm just covering it
maybe I should have taken on deform
maybe I should have done that
hmm and then I maybe would have had the
the the the C file open and would have
been better
maybe okay now here going show to
simplify meta so but and get into an i
QP position unless he takes with the
night it's possible
yeah bishop chicks didn't work out that
well so he has to take with the Queen
very bit of an ammonia setup yeah but
it's it's okay for him I mean why does
why this knob not terrible him okay I
can take a three right it's something
wrong with this move don't see anything
don't see anything wrong with it why is
that working okay yeah at the end I
still have from clockwork the aide
[Music]
yeah okay so I'm pulling up the a pawn
okay let I'm not unhappy about yeah I
just noticed that I'm in the self pin I
can't do this it's it's not it's not
really what I wanted initially but it is
okay I think you should a five I can
take so I can play like this now so we
trade rooks you know it is it is a
fairly huge advantage and should I
should win this with good technical
plane dangers always opposite colored
bishops ending of course that is the
thing that could happen here if I can
trade but just can trade the bishops it
should be very it should be very doable
but not it's not that easy how to do it
maybe maybe this is the idea to go a
form should Bishop c3 I've got 95 yeah
that's true
[Music]
yeah that is very true I wanted to go
with you for but that is obviously not
not really all that great
no that's difficult it's also very
difficult to get the pawn going oh yeah
he had a four already that would have
been interesting
it's going towards the pawn here yeah I
don't I don't see a great way forward
really don't oopsie 7 g7 maybe no
doesn't do that okay that are not
unhappy about an IG three iconic plate
that stood for night everyone
I'm getting all the way to a forum it's
probably probably going to be a draw and
this I can trap the trap the bishop he's
running running for this pawn
I cannot trap the bishop unfortunately
now I don't I don't I cannot win this
unfortunately
[Music]
you know this is a draw I think should
always be able to sacrifice the bishop
it's just a job
ya know it's somewhat weird game
I didn't didn't quite understand many
things okay so he went with this strange
moves before I mean this is kind of
nappies napa d7 looks normal okay 194 I
think also that looks like a normal move
maybe Quincy tune yeah and I should
probably think about taking but he can
maybe take maybe you can take on you for
no that's not a good move says something
completely wrong with this at the end at
63 okay okay okay so because I mean this
is this is this is excellent yeah this
is very good for me it's not it's good
at that thought I mean it's it's it's an
advantage but okay yeah I mean it's
better I think then then the game now he
somehow gets some play I mean that's
it's still not great okay he takes is
better because he had c5 well that's
that's not a move you consider really
yeah but pawn takes I think I'm very
very fine yeah I can take then he and so
on so he had to take with the knight
takes takes and I'm winning this pawn
and I'm somehow I'm playing this somehow
playing this badly would be one the only
move that keeps it keeps it going yeah
yeah the engine courts at almost equal
that's kind of frustrating and this is
also wrong I mean this position can
never be equal zero point two is also
not enough
I mean Black has been
chances with the pawn there's just no
way around that but I didn't play it
well I'm okay up to this and now I have
to play differently I think like g6 okay
and now in five I don't I should not go
if I should not go in five I mean this
is this is a matter of being very
patient and trying to push him back this
idea of going with the e pawn is
probably wrong yeah it is the wrong idea
it is a wrong idea I was I was not
really registering Bishop c6 I thought
okay this is this is something that I
generally like to see where my bishop
will be able to hear like or the other
way around yeah covered both pawns that
looks okay and if I get a foreigner also
be would be would be fine with that but
Bishop c6 them and maybe for anyway I
thought about it but I couldn't quite
figure out if that is good or not I can
I can do this and I saw this line but
yeah I couldn't couldn't quite see that
I'm making any headway and I don't think
it's metaphoric but now it's it's get
it's getting a bit awkward because he
has this f4 move that he somehow never
played I've expected f4 and I wasn't all
that sure how to reply to that Bishop c5
this is a good reply and because there
is this this idea when is this place is
probably really equal now the way it
turned out nothing much was going on
maybe I had had some chances near the
end that I didn't quite exploit yeah 93
I can't do that right away I don't think
it makes a huge difference as I have to
get the King involved anyway this one
and the engine and
is giving a draw and then that is
probably really it wrong the engine
should can calculate somebody if it's a
winner or not I don't think there is
anything yeah now I have to take and
then this is just a drawn I just have no
way forward and I went here to get you
to clarify the situation for the draw
don't think you can do much there it's
just a draw the key point is probably me
playing a five in the Sun this end game
which is not giving me any winning
winning opportunities it's going to be
difficult really because the the bishop
is always covering squares and you you
have a hard time to make to make
progress but I should at least yeah get
to get to get somewhere yeah maybe not
to win but somewhere and the way I
played it I didn't have any chance okay
guys thanks for watching